Tracy is a child was a child say in
children's home desperate to be fostered
and I got the original idea because I
saw some photos of real children who and
there was a special campaign to try and
get foster parents for them and I
couldn't help wondering what must it
feel like to be in this situation and so
suddenly just this character this feisty
determined little kid came into my mind
who can be really difficult at times but
she's no one else to stick up for her so
she sticks up for herself and I loved
writing that story it was one of the
very few that seemed literally to write
itself I didn't really think it would be
a particular success life for children
can be rough around the edges is that
what you wanted to show did you want
books that children could identify with
exactly I mean I didn't have a very sort
of custard middle-class upbringing we
lived on a council estate my mum and dad
will forever having roles and although I
loved reading and read my way through
all the the blindness and the stret
fields and everything else I could get
my hands on in the library I couldn't
help thinking that these children aren't
really like me and so and not that I was
particularly like a Tracy Beaker but
I've always been interested in children
who don't quite fit in and so yes Tracy
I think has to be my most favorite
character here other books as well
they've never really shied away from the
harsh realities of life you've been very
upfront and honest with your readers
some of whom are as young as eight years
old you've covered subjects like
abandonment divorce alcoholism poverty
depression suicide and of course the
care system is interesting because how
do you find the tone and the language to
speak to children because these are some
subjects that their parents will find it
difficult talk to them about anything
violent anything too upsetting is off
off the page it's happened and it will
be mentioned
but I would hate to traumatize any child
it's very very difficult because
children nowadays when they they watch
television or they look at things on
YouTube they they are far more aware
than perhaps adults realize all sorts of
things going on I try and write as
truthfully as I can but I try and be
comforting I do think humor is a way of
coping with bad things what do you think
children worry about today in 2018 what
do you think their main concerns are
because you're all about putting
yourself in the mindset of the child
I think they worry about having friends
and there are lots of anguished emails I
get from you know somebody's friend has
gone off with somebody else I think
they're far more worried about the way
they look now it's the sort of thing but
you know an iris a child a dystopian
novel would be all about a way that
children young people their minds are
being manipulated and now in enough
sometimes benign way I think that is
happening now you've brought Tracy
Beaker back we are exploring the adult
Tracy Beaker through the eyes of her
daughter are these the kind of issues
that you're going to find yourself
writing about and exploring yourself
this book supposedly by Jessica Tracy's
daughter and if there's a sequel at all
I think we will keep just about ten or
eleven a report that came out recently
from the Children's Commissioner which
found that 15 hours and vulnerable
children under the age of five and
living in households with with what
they're calling a toxic trio of domestic
abuse drug or alcohol addiction mental
health problems as well and some of
these children may not even be on social
services radar so the number could be
far higher the Children's Commissioner
herself Anna Longfield said more funding
is urgently needed but the shortfall by
2020 could be as much as two billion
pounds should social care be better
funded
I think definitely it should be that the
trouble is this such a demand I did hear
a while ago about skin somewhere where
they had
middle-aged women who successfully
brought up a lot of children to take
families who were struggling under their
wing a bit and maybe you know if a man
is exhausted with several kids all
around her just to bustle in every now
and then and say put your feet up dear
I'll do the washing up and you know why
is it do you think the baby is crying so
much and all the rest of it who knows
how that might work it's my more social
responsibility need government
intervention so I think so you're back
into the groove now with Tracy Beaker
you wouldn't commit suicide and I spoke
to you about it a little earlier but now
there are so many new themes to explore
and Tracy is an adult dealing with
different issues are you tempted I am
tempted because I have been talking to
quite a lot of people about my mom Tracy
Beaker and many people have said we'll
come on what does happen next adjacent
Tracy so I'm thinking about it but
certainly it won't be the next book
because that's already written and
that's something else entirely but I
Tracy is there in my head still so is
Jess I I don't think they're going to go
away